how'd you get out of it I didn't get out
of it and it wasn't funny and it wasn't
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You Thomas
please help me welcome to sake of
everybody man mr. al Jackson on his eyes
[Applause]
every comics are telling LP tonight as
made it to a point in their career what
you can kind of pick and choose gigs you
do what you want you skip what you don't
want to do oh this is one of my first
shows and what y'all need to know about
this gig is I was early in my career I
was broke this was roof money
this was the rain doesn't hit your head
bunny I was gonna do this show I was
going to the show so the gig was a
college in Florida they put me up in
this really nice hotel and now there
were two things that kind of stood out
about the gig just start first of all
they wanted me to wear a suit which
again fine I was going to show second
thing the gig was at 8 o'clock in the
morning which yes good time for stand-up
you know I'm saying you want some eggs
with those dick jokes so didn't matter
I'm gonna do the show no matter what I'm
doing the show so I'm sitting in my room
I rented the suit from Men's Warehouse
and I'm sitting in my room and it's like
740 and I'm walking out because a gig
was in the where it was it was in the
downstairs the ballroom where people get
married so inside the hotel so I'm
getting ready to go to the gig and I'm
reaching for my door hand I'm like wait
let me just see how much time they want
me to do on the show because sometimes
you get the gig and college gigs they
once you do an hour because college gigs
are so different they're all different
they don't high comedy clubs college
gigs sometimes you do like University of
Colorado it's already sold out the end
you kill it and they carry you out that
bitch like Rudy and the next day you do
the University of Nevada and the shows
at noon in the cafeteria and the mic is
on the floor and somebody just
says just pick the mic up and start
talking I'm like that's not how comedy
shows
people are getting fisted so just
remember that all college gigs of
difference so I was like let me just
check and see how much shine this
college gig want me to do and I looked
and they want to be into an hour which
is fine I can do an hour but they didn't
want me to do stand-up they wanted me to
do in our speech on note-taking an
organization I know I know I know
it's like 7:40 and I'm like this must be
a mistake but let me just make sure this
back I tell you back when this was back
I had an old Mac power book when those
big silver Mac's and yes so I just
pulled up I just just in case they want
me to do some chilling no taken let me
just pull up so I pulled up an outline
they should be a teacher so I could
swear my way through this if I
have to so I pulled up like just a basic
outline so if I had to like refer to a
worst-case scenario they wanted me to do
this I'm fine so get my MacBook go
downstairs get to the bottom of the
elevator and the elevator doors open up
and the liaison from the college goes
are you Jackson I go yeah and she goes
you're late she swings opens double
doors of this ballroom there are 750
college students and suits pantsuits
MacBooks
I passed ready to hear this Negro give a
speech on something he's never heard of
and I know y'all are like trying to get
ahead of me like y'all are smart people
like y'all are like well how'd you get
out of it what's the funny part get to
the joke what's the funny part I didn't
get out of it and it wasn't funny
and it wasn't okay I woke up there got
my Men's Wearhouse suit on I have a
giant Mack with me for no reason and I
went up and it was like I'm a comic so
if you give me a mic at least I can move
around a kind of it but it was like one
of them podiums he's got like that
Burger King microphone that so you can't
even like move you're just like behind
the podium like Napoleon Dynamite so I
put my macbook down and this is this is
the part that like I hope y'all feel me
when I say this I'm in this ballroom
with all these kids looking at me and
people that have masks and feel this I
open up my Mac and the battery just died
like as I opened it it was just like
instantly was just that great Apple I
was like oh but I can't let my face
say old cuz I'm already gonna bomb
with with the help of the computer I was
already done I said just I was like
so this is happening and I know a lot of
people are like but then what happened
like how'd you get out of it I didn't
get out I stayed up there and I ate my
dick for now
because I was gonna do this show and my
first manager told me if you don't do
your time that's how colleges don't pay
you like stay up there do your time I
was gonna do the show I was going to do
the show
and I stayed up there for an hour and I
know like this is a comedic setting but
you have to remove yourself and think
about how long 60 minutes is in the real
time in real time like how long 60
minutes is you know like every third
year is your turn to give the
Thanksgiving prayer and it's super
awkward and how long is that
forty Mississippi think about if you had
to give the Thanksgiving prayer for an
hour this year only you didn't know what
the prayer was I stayed up there and I
bombed the college kids they didn't know
what was going on everything I felt
worse for them because it was like I
might as well have just gone up there
and put on a French film backwards like
they didn't know what was happening I
didn't know what was happening and I'm
just bombing I'm sweating when I don't
sweat at all on stage when you're
bombing like sweat starts coming from
just like your side and like weird
places and it was young black dude that
booked me and he is like he's got his
cell phone on that red light and he's
waving to give me the throat slash like
get off the stage get off the stage I'm
like nope you not gonna baby and I
stayed up there for the whole the whole
time I get on stage and I have to walk
back through the crowd of college kids
that just are stunned that there's were
like no one talking and I go to get my
check from from the black dude and he's
so mad at me he throws my cheque on the
on the ground I needed the money I went
to go pick it up and as I reached down
to get it like this big six foot three
like 50 year old white guy brush past me
so hard like if he had done it like in a
bar like this it would have started
like I mean omelets knock me over and he
goes straight up on the stage angrily
and starts giving a speech on
note-taking and organization
funny story kids the college up
and sent me his contract I was supposed
to do 15 minutes of jokes to liven up
his boring ass note-taking stream and
instead I did his piece for him only
with zero knowledge because I was gonna
do that show guys have been out exactly